one of the gigs that you got After That
70s Show was being a voice on the Family
Guy Oh no I got that during 70s I was 15
I couldn't yeah I was 15 years old at
when I got they needed a voice for the
character met Griffin I guess was the
they had someone and she quit yeah I
know why why would you quit a gig like
that because you just didn't think it
out I just I can't I'm so grateful that
this woman was like this is not for me
right because this is the greatest gig
in the whole world I mean if you think
about it from a career standpoint it it
it's great money right I meaning and you
go in what for a day and do you work
with the other voice actors on that show
no is Seth McFarland he's not even there
anymore he doesn't he doesn't show up at
first and teach you how to do the voice
and all that in the beginning like for
years he was always there and I think
just as the show went on and as
everybody kind of found their own
footing we all just show up at our own
time on like a Thursday